welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we are hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is Angela
Goss and today we're here to talk about
connected healthcare enabling secure
entry points into the cloud with Chrome
you can ask questions anytime on the
platform and we'll have Googlers on
standby waiting to answer them so let's
get started
googles mission is to organize the
world's information and make it
universally accessible and useful within
healthcare and what we share this year
at hims 18 is that Google Cloud School
is very much a reflection of Google's
overall mission applying this mission to
healthcare means using open standards to
help enable data sharing and interactive
collaboration while also providing a
secure platform to kick things off today
here's a brief video to illustrate what
that might look like in business there
are a lot of moving parts Google cloud
helps you connect the dots use
Chromebooks with G suite to make
communication more open and productive
access real-time data from Google cloud
platform keep inventory up-to-date
automatically add smart chips to your
valuable products to monitor location
and conditions in real-time
[Music]
get instant updates through Decimus
workers out in the field
reduce costs improve efficiency and
ensure security with remote device
manager
streamline operations and stay in
control
with connected tools and services from
Google Play
you
excellent so where you sit in the
ecosystem be it a care provider
researcher supporting staff or
healthcare decision maker technology is
changing the way health care is
delivered common priorities for digital
innovation among healthcare systems
hospitals and care facilities include
improving the Wellness of a community
through improved access to patient care
be it retail clinic telehealth home
monitoring or other virtual Health Care
option reducing the cost and complexity
of IT and increasing agility
particularly in the face of budget and
funding uncertainties supporting new
healthcare business models by providing
anytime anywhere access to patient
information via remote and multi-channel
access to mobile and web applications
strengthening protection and defense of
pahi and other sensitive health details
by leveraging information security in
the face of new and more sophisticated
cyber threats improving the quality of
patient services and business decisions
through more and better use of big data
analytics and IOT four key trends
transforming the industry and driving
the needs for those priorities are as
follows the ongoing need to reduce costs
in the delivery of care health care
systems around the world are struggling
to deliver satisfactory care in the face
of budget cuts and increasing demands
from an aging and growing global
population workplace challenges
contributing to this need are the time
and staff shortages as physicians are
pressured to deliver an increasing
number of preventative Services follow
guidelines engage in evidence-based
practice and deliver patient centered
care in managerially driven
organizations they struggle with how
much control they have over their own
time according to the biannual
physician survey only 14% believe they
have the time they need to provide the
highest standards of care
additionally the current worldwide
shortage of physicians nurses and other
health workers is 7 million and the gap
is widening some doctors are looking to
leave the profession a mud amid burrow
burnout and low morale due to regulatory
and paperwork burdens and a loss of
clinical autonomy according to the World
Health Organization training can also be
a factor the bgl group reports that
approximately 40% of employees who
receive poor job training are likely to
leave their positions within the first
year the second trend transforming the
industry is the increasing threat of
cyberattacks and data loss with growing
concerns about cyber security and the
loss of sensitive information this is
changing and the risk of not overhauling
and moving forward with new viable
technology solutions is becoming the
greater threat the Ponemon Institute
estimated an average breach cost of 3.5
million dollars in 2017 with a 27%
probability that a US company would
experience a breach in the next 24
months costing between 1.1 and 3.8
million dollars if you multiply that
estimate per record cost for a breach
across the industry multiple breaches
combined would potentially cost hundreds
of millions of dollars
the third key trend transport driving
transformation in health care is higher
service expectations from digitally
savvy patients today's digitally savvy
patients expect on-demand personalized
service digitalization and the
implementation of mobile strategy
strategies can no longer be approached
as an afterthought in the delivery of
care and patient experience Mobile is
becoming ubiquitous in healthcare
playing a significant role as the
industry continues to adopt a
patient-centered approach healthcare
leaders are now seeking to improve the
patient experience through tailoring
patient engagement strategies to meet
the expectations of their digitally
savvy patients one example of this is
the proliferation of mobile devices in
healthcare as it helps to reduce
paperwork time by 60% and increase
patient base time by 29% and the fourth
key trend driving transformation of
healthcare is advancing disease
prediction and prevention through
insights and machine learning from high
end diagnostic imaging systems that let
doctors catch deadly diseases like
cancer in their early stages to voice
recognition
in the operating room which helped
doctors get a better view of parts of
the body while operating technology has
made life easier for both doctors and
patients however although AI is a hot
healthcare topic some haven't felt ready
meaning it still needs to be translated
into reality especially in an industry
as complex as healthcare among the
challenges to widespread use are the
acceptance of AI applications and
clinical practice difficulty leveraging
divergent personal Network devices and
AI solutions and access to quality
training data on AI applications and
health and gaps and data streams as
healthcare moves beyond the walls of the
hospital so healthcare IT must move
beyond the data center the need to adopt
digital tools and develop new strategies
to change the way care is delivered to
patients and residents may seem obvious
but the care industry sometimes lags
behind others and its use of technology
it's not that healthcare providers don't
want to try new innovative tools to
support better models but the risk of
failure has often been deemed too high
the implementation of cloud strategies
and digitalization can no longer be
approached as an afterthought in the
delivery of care and patient experience
it will not only help meet the needs of
today's digitally savvy patients it also
has a potential to impact every aspect
of care delivery and operations
enabling more efficient utilization of
resources more time with patients at the
point of care and a more secure and
governed working model like it has in
other industries and commercial
enterprises cloud-based technology will
play a pivotal role in overhauling
health and social care environments
providing care professionals with secure
mobile access to information and
resources at the point of delivery and
opening up new ways to collaborate and
improve the quality of patient care in a
traditional computing model you would
bring data to the individual data
sharing in that model essentially
implies data copying costs can be high
and unpredictable
there are burdens associated with
installs integrations and
upgrades data silos detract from
insights and correlation and software
deployment can be inflexible but in a
cloud computing model you bring
individuals to the data in this model
simplicity is king and users truly share
data costs for services are predictable
the focus is on business value not
managing infrastructure there is a
comprehensive patient centric view and
apps and compute can be done anywhere
let's go back I'm sorry about that
Google cloud offers many tools within
its enterprise portfolio to address
health care's digital priorities and the
trends driving digital transformation
that we just discussed with more than a
billion users leveraging seven of those
products each month the solutions range
from storage and compute machine
learning and artificial intelligence
productivity and collaboration to the
platform that serves as a secure gateway
to the cloud Chrome Enterprise chrome
Enterprise is a license you activate to
centrally manage enrole deploy monitor
and secure Chrome devices running Chrome
OS the central management console offers
a host of features to keep your
organization safe and enable your
end-users to work smart including access
to enterprise app storefronts deep
security controls 24 by 7 support as
well as integration with cloud and
on-premise tools for your business the
platform is secured by design the
platform leverages comprehensive AI
driven threat detection and granular
policies to protect your data and your
users custom security protocols for
individuals or groups of users and you
can easily provision manage and secure
devices lost or stolen devices can be
disabled within minutes with over 200
security policies that may be applied to
either the user or the device granular
and flexible controls enable centralized
fleet management and updates this
ensures compliance of IT policies no
matter
which user is accessing a device or
which device is being accessed by the
end user this drives value for your
organization increase your employees
productivity by ensuring they spend less
time waiting for new updates automatic
manage updates take place in the
background without getting in the way
and without those distractions that
sometimes you find in a local platform
users can get more out of their day
because it is simplifies simplified and
centralized resulting in a 63% lower
administration cost overall then for the
end user the platform means secure
application access whether it's a SAS
app virtual desktop environment or a
favorite Android application available
through Google Play for enterprise users
have access to all of their data right
from the chrome launcher in the bottom
left corner of the screen the platform
is built for the cloud worker when you
deploy Chrome to your care team
clinicians become untethered from local
storage and are able to enter and access
patient records quickly and collaborate
with the extended team and finally while
health care has a unique set of
challenges to simultaneously deliver and
protect pH I workers still care about
having the state-of-the-art devices and
cool features to get the job done with
enterprise grade Hardware the good news
is we have both an healthcare security
is a top concern chrome Enterprise
extends comprehensive security with a
multi-layered approach each Chrome
device arrives encrypted out of the box
through Hardware back security and a TPM
chip verified boot of Chrome OS uses the
TPM chip to ensure integrity of the
device and tell if the OS is genuine or
not tab sandboxing needs each webpage
and application runs on its in its own
restricted environment which prevents
against attacks such as cross-site
scripting when run an ephemeral mode
browsing information is not left behind
on a device because the profile is
deleted immediately after the last
browser window associated with a profile
is closed and with AI driven threat
detection Safe Browsing reports over
1,000 instances of suspected malware
every minute by showing users a warning
message before they visit potentially
dangerous sites or download a harmful
app and again with AI driven threat
detection in Google Play protect all
apps are automatically scanned for a
malware before and after you enter
install them then regular updates and
patches round out this multi-layered
approach Chrome OS gets an update every
six weeks with security patches rolling
out every two to three weeks and on top
of all that Google hosts a bug bounty
program again all of this happens in the
background will an end-user is at work
meaning disruptions are minimized and
uptime is maximized
once again Chrome OS becomes ready for
healthcare through the Chrome Enterprise
license which unlocks the central
management console the granular controls
from the 200-plus security policies
allow you to customize and curate your
end-users experience be it in cloud
worker or one device to one end user
assignment mode public session or many
users to one device assignment or kiosk
mode which extends a single app on a
device or displays information through
digital signage the policies can be
extended per user or per device based
upon your existing and user segmentation
while the Chrome enterprise console
provides a feature-rich solution we also
recognize the needs of health care to
support overall clinical and business
work clothes
as well as legacy apps with that in mind
Google has partnered with top uem
vendors such as VMware Citrix IBM and
Cisco to extend flexible EMM management
options and integrate Chrome Enterprise
seamlessly with your existing
environment we also offer IDP solutions
including Google Cloud identity and
Microsoft Active Directory to easily
define a wide range of criteria and
control which types of websites apps
and extensions can be accessed by users
from an end-user perspective again
workers care about having the
state-of-the-art device with cool
features and access to the apps they
need to get their job done a variety of
form factors are available to match your
needs from traditional clamshell to
convertible - and one with stylists as
well as chrome boxes and chrome bases
Hardware options include the latest
Intel processor models with 8 plus gigs
of RAM on device storage 10 hours of
battery life and various builds from
entry to rugged to premium to suit your
use case Google works with top om
vendors including Samsung Lenovo a sir
Asus HP and Dell so you can continue
working with your favorite brand or om
of record combining the software
hardware and management platform that we
just discussed is how Chrome Enterprise
enables the connected experience in
healthcare for staff back-out office
administrators and patients alike carers
and patients have better access to
information in real time reliance on
outdated processes as removed as you
integrate with legacy systems and
tech-savvy patients are served with
premium devices let's take a moment to
discuss each one in more detail
according to the Journal of medical
health and informatics mobile devices
can help reduce paperwork time by 60
percent and increase patient base time
by 29% mobilize and connect healthcare
staff with chrome devices and empower
them to deliver more seamless care
experiences virtualization allows users
to access customer clinical legacy
applications and address data security
leading VDI solutions from Citrix and
VMware as well as other providers secure
access to natively installed
applications and through the chrome
enterprise central management console
enrollment of the experience takes less
than a minute from a user perspective
free up healthcare profession
from fixed workstations and provide them
with easy mobile access to the files and
information they need on the go meaning
they can deliver the best care and
achieve more in their day chrome OS is
built fundamentally to reduce downtime
for workers devices boot in under 10
seconds and come out of standby in under
three
additionally Chrome syncs apps policies
and preferences across devices so that
workers have continuity and can pick up
from where they left off across multiple
devices in a day
be it an exam room hallway medical cart
front desk or if using a loaner device
and that same encrypted cloud profile
which follows one user across multiple
devices means that one device can be
easily shared by multiple users while
ensuring that their day is that by the
policies that IT extends either way if
you're following the end user or
following the device all OS updates are
happening in the background meaning
users never experience downtime due to
update notifications then with that same
cloud-based profile staff can easily
communicate and coordinate a single
consistent care plan across a team with
the adoption of G suite moving along to
our second use case being the
non-clinical or back office
administration according to Gartner
and the US Department of Labor the
amount of time an average employee
spends searching for documents per year
is 400 hours ESG predicts 1.97
million dollars in savings and benefits
over a three-year period using Chrome
Enterprise on Chromebooks including 63
percent lower administration costs
through improved operational efficiency
with a fast setup and intuitive UI users
can be productive in minutes with chrome
devices by including cloud enabled
devices information and files are
readily accessible allowing staff to
move away from paper documents reduce
filing costs and free up space in the
office in the same way that we discussed
with a clinical use case Chrome devices
can replace or integrate with legacy
application legacy systems by providing
and secure
access to virtualize desktops and apps
for back-office administrators as well
lost or stolen device no problem
IT admins can shut down and wipe all
devices on a network from a remote
location
barring unauthorized access
approximately 40% of employees who
receive poor job training might leave
their positions within the first year
you can improve onboarding and education
opportunities with shared devices and
cloud-based resources host training and
instructional videos easily utilizing
the familiar YouTube platform or how is
custom training apps with managed Google
Play and maintain control over app
development and shared device public
session mode any employee could securely
access the data and resources they need
on any company controlled Chrome device
at any location providing a more time
efficient and convenient process to fit
around staff here again individual cloud
profiles allow employees to sign in from
any device and only access the data
they're permitted to see and for our
last use case we'll examine today
patients are increasingly looking at
healthcare options with a consumer
driven mindset on demand kiosks enable
healthcare providers to build more
opportunities for tech driven
self-service and autonomy as well as
reducing staff administration time and
manual processes with chrome enterprise
power interactive self-service stations
that have a 61 percent lower device cost
and kiosk mode compared to competitors
through the central management console
you may deploy single or multiple apps
through kiosk mode to ensure guests can
only access the content you want them to
see and remotely manage Chrome devices
from anywhere to control a network of
displays when configured in enrollment
type public session mode all local user
data is removed from the device at the
end of each session preventing
unauthorized access from anyone else
Chrome this means that chrome is an
affordable reliable and flexible device
platform that makes digital signage
practical for one screen or a thousand
with chrome hospitals and clinics can
easily deliver information and services
in real-time to streamline operations
and enhance the patient and staff
experience on the patient side use
kiosks to improve patient well-being
through digital signage and informative
communications using distraction in
clinical environments has been shown to
reduce perceptions of pain lower anxiety
and stress and benefit clinicians by
creating a calmer environment for them
to work often resulting in quicker
treatment times placing informative
digital screens and waiting areas can
help lower anxiety alleviate frustration
and reduce the perceived wait time by
35% in tandem with Google's CMS partners
create dynamic digital messaging to
greet and communicate with patients via
personalized messages secure public
kiosks and provide shorter wait times
and a better guest overall experience by
streamlining the check-in process and
they can also enable patients to order
and request assistance securely browse
the web or stream content for
entertainment in summary chrome can help
in many aspects of your health care
organization from clinical workflow to
business operations for care providers
Chrome's cloud connected endpoint
simplifies and secures access to
critical apps reduced complexity and
ease of use means more time caring for
patients fastboot times means quicker
access to clinical information long
battery life means more flexibility and
mobility for the patient Chrome provides
personalized digital service and more
access to information and for businesses
health care organizations can save money
simplify their IT and manage risk to
share an example of a current customer
leveraging Google cloud technologies in
health care Middlesex Hospital has
embraced an innovative computing
infrastructure more than 3000 employees
through the throughout the healthcare
network now count on G suite including
calendaring scheduling email instant
messaging and websites and the browser
that powers them Chrome to easily and
powerfully collaborate with one another
the challenge they were facing was that
their legacy solution was not fulfilling
requirements needed to match their high
patient satisfaction ratings the
solution after moving to Chrome browser
in 2010 the hospital began to use G
suite seeing quick uptake from staff and
Chromebooks were then later adopted for
training purposes to start and then the
foot put footprint was expanded the
benefits massive cost savings on their
software licensing costs legacy browsers
and healthcare applications were still
supported including SSO VDI and their
primary each EHR because Chromebooks
allowed the hospital to virtualize
essential clinical applications and
support so that's a wrap on connected
endpoints in healthcare thank you for
joining us today
stay tuned for live QA and we will be
back in less than a minute
welcome back now we're going to take a
look at the live Q&A that's come in from
the audience today so the first question
is how is Chrome Enterprise licensed
Chrome enterprise is available in either
an annual license or a perpetual license
and typically we would encourage a
customer to start the conversation
either with a member of my team or with
their preferred reseller partner okay
what else does Chrome Enterprise require
G suite while chrome and G suite work
very well hand-in-hand and we would say
that one makes the other even more
useful and productive G suite is not
required to run Chrome and it looks like
on our next question which is can I
access office 365 on Chrome the answer
to that question similar yes you can
access office 365 through the Google
Play app which is available again
through the console so you can just
install your office productivity apps
through the Google Play Store and then
looks like we have another question can
my clinical team use a proximity card to
login
actually yes so this is very popular and
we get this question a lot in healthcare
a in healthcare workflows badge tap and
go I have a badge here at Google
provider or a clinician would come in
they would badge tap in and they would
get in to their session securely we do
offer a badge tap and go with proximity
cards through our partner health cast
and as we continue to expand our
relationships with different
manufacturers and healthcare
organizations to make the solution even
better for our customers we hope to
continue to partner and integrate more
solutions that round out healthcare
workflows so it looks like that is the
end of the QA so with that said thank
you
watching our next cloud air will be on
July 10th